musician moby has called on the cop 26
climate change conference here in
glasgow to make the climate damaging
impacts of animal agriculture central to
the agenda if world leaders hope to make
meaningful pledges to avert catastrophic
climate breakdown and moby who's not
just a musician but also an animal
rights activist and also supporter of
the humane society international joins
me now from los angeles i'm delighted to
say great to see you
moby we all know don't we that animal
agriculture damages
the climate but you feel that that
message isn't getting heard enough here
in glasgow is that right
yeah well i mean remember cop 21 there
wasn't a single panel or mention
of the consequences of meat and dairy
production and i was hoping that things
would change for cop26 because obviously
public awareness has evolved
but once again you look at the
legislative agenda cop 26 and there's no
mention
of
almost no mention of animal agriculture
and methane production and rainforest
deforestation and the other incredibly
deleterious consequences of using meat
and dairy for food
so what would you like them to be
hearing then what would the message be
the message would be one of honesty
you know it reminds me of a conversation
i had with al gore
a few years ago
and i'm paraphrasing what vice president
gore said but he basically said the role
of meat and dairy production in climate
change is the true inconvenient truth
you know it's the truth that politicians
don't want to talk about that corporate
corporations don't want to talk about
it's the truth that so many people don't
want to address for so many different
reasons and my hope
is simply
that there will be a change and people
will be willing to look at the causes of
climate change
um it's international vegan day uh i
think today um one inconvenient truth is
that you're never going to tell people
that they can't eat meat you can't ban
meat altogether can you
well i don't know it's certainly i mean
if that were to is that what you'd like
to see would you like to see meat banned
uh what i would like to see first and
foremost is for me to cost what it
actually costs you know to factor in the
direct costs because
here in the united states and i assume
in the uk as well and in europe we
subsidize meat and dairy production so
much
that if it weren't for these subsidies a
family of four going to burger king
would spend about a hundred dollars
on a meal so i'm just saying remove the
subsidies stop subsidizing an industry
that is destroying human health and is
destroying the climate on the only home
that we have
um you say that the issue isn't being
heard at all
really here in glasgow but boris johnson
recently has said that he sees lab-grown
eco-friendly alternatives to meters as
being the future i mean you must welcome
that
i welcome anything
that puts us on a path
that will enable us to and i know this
might sound like hyperbole and i
apologize because it's not hyperbole i
applaud anything that will enable us to
avert catastrophe and at present i feel
like so many of us have our heads in the
sand like
you can't
fix a problem
if you're simply unwilling to look
at the empirically supported reasons why
the problem exists and so if it's lab
grown meat if it's
ending subsidies for meat and dairy
production whatever it takes to sort of
prevent this unfolding catastrophe
but of course it's not just meat eating
is it that causes uh huge issues with
the climate i was reading today about
asparagus one study has shown that for
every one kilogram of asparagus eaten in
the united kingdom 5.3 kilograms of
carbon dioxide is produced now that's no
good either is it
uh i mean all agriculture has
consequences there's no such thing i
mean all you could go even further and
be philosophical and say all actions
have consequences
of course
all agriculture requires water and
more often than not has co2
emissions but compared to meat and dairy
i mean even the united nations admits
that meat and dairy production is the
third leading cause of climate change so
i don't think asparagus
ranks as one of the global
leading causes for climate change and
keep in mind i'm a vegan and i don't
really like asparagus asparagus that
much i'm not going to stick up for us
yeah i mean that was just an example i
mean there are plenty more examples
aren't there of uh you know and
fertilizer and the way we farm crops and
all the rest of it um
how much of your campaign is actually
about um
the climate and the effects that meat
eating has on the climate and how much
is actually about the ethics of meat
eating because we know you're a huge
animal lover you do a huge amount of
work for animal welfare is it more about
that than actually about the climate
well in this instance especially with
cop26 happening now
my focus is on the climate i mean
personally
i'm a vegan and an animal rights
activist because i just can't in good
conscience be involved in anything that
causes animal suffering or contributes
to animal suffering but right now the
focus has to be on the climate and i
apologize for stating the obvious
but every issue that we care about
depends upon a stable climate and i
think that unfortunately a lot of people
still think that they can have opinions
about climate change we can have
opinions about jazz we can have opinions
about
the timothy chalamet version of dune we
can't have opinions about climate change
because it's climate change is just an
incontrovertible fact
okay can we have an opinion about this
then boris johnson again today in his
speech mentioned scientists in new
zealand who are
working out ways of injecting cows so
that they produce less methane now isn't
that a sensible way to go so meat eaters
can still eat meat but the reduction in
methane means that we're helping the
planet uh i mean not to be dismissive
but it does remind me a little bit of
that old monty python skit where they
dig a trench in the beach for actors to
walk in and then they make the actors
walk on boxes
seems like there might be a simpler way
to address the solution when you're
injecting cows to have them produce less
methane
there might simply be a more direct way
of getting cows to produce less methane
perhaps by having fewer cows because the
other thing
that doesn't take into account is sort
of like
the ancillary carbon footprint of animal
agriculture which is rainforest
deforestation
um water production
moving
livestock to and from slaughterhouses
etc like there's such a huge knock-on
effect so
i i don't mean to make light of it but
it does seem like there might be a more
logical effective way of addressing the
consequences of animal agriculture
okay uh it's been a pleasure speaking to
you and getting your thoughts thank you
very much indeed moby much appreciated
oh thank you for having me